foreign
if you were watching the show right now
you see a very very cool looking
handsome stud uh to my to my uh
and you're thinking Ken would never ever
be able to hang out with somebody like
that in real life some might call him a
snack okay oh really I feel very weird
about calling him a snack I'll be honest
Jade's better half I don't know if I'm
supposed to say that either the first
time I've ever been called it because
you're on the shower
but I believe you can call him a snack
yes I can but I on the other hand I'm
gonna stay away from that uh but he's in
here for a reason and uh you know we've
been we've been hearing from you the
people uh about this economy that we're
in where people are making more money
but Jade you know this things cost a
whole lot more money inflation has been
stubborn those grocery bills uh
everything bills today's prices are not
yesterday's prices that's exactly right
and so what we've seen Jade as a result
of this is we've seen the gig economy
which is a new way of saying the side
hustle economy maybe I drive a little
bit of uber I do some delivery I do a
lot of different things we're seeing the
freelance economy for white collar
workers and I'll give you one example
maybe a programmer who can obviously do
some high-end programming they're
getting contract work through freelance
because companies are uh not as excited
about offering a full-time salary when
they can get you at a contract level so
all that said the side hustle is a big
search engine thing right now people
want to know what can I do how can I do
it because I want some extra money and
so we were talking about this and and
this guy to my left uh he's a stud in a
lot of ways uh but you guys figured out
the side hustle thing and he's got a
really cool gig uh as a side hustle so I
wanted you to set that up and then I'm
going to ask him how he got there
because I think our T our audience can
learn something from him yeah people
want to know how to do this and you know
a lot of folks know our story we paid
off 460 000 of debt and that wasn't just
with our you know day-to-day income we
did a lot of side hustles and our Mantra
early on was instead of going now I'm
not poo-pooing this because you do what
you got to do but for us instead of
going out and doing the Ubers and the
doordashes and the instacarts we were
like I feel like we can take our skills
and make more money doing things that we
enjoy doing that are already
um a commodity for other people we can
offer services so it was anything from
dog training to Sam was designing
websites and both of us were teaching
lessons I did voice lessons Sam Did You
Know piano and guitar lessons and um out
of that came this idea that hey like we
can set our own hours we can make money
and and during the pandemic you know
everything was shut down us being in
Entertainment Earth thing was shut down
and uh Sam came up to me he goes hey I
know that we're watching every dollar
right now but
do you think that we can arrange for me
to pull 170 out of the budget because I
have a side hustle that I want to invest
in
and I'm like oh boy you know
everything's shut down I'm like you want
to do 170 For What and he's like Jade I
want to sell I want to resell Jordans
Air Jordan
sneakers if you're over 50 tennis shoes
if you're I don't know if you call them
shoes basketball shoes sneakers sneakers
thank you oh sneaker still works for the
youngsters that is what that's what you
call it yeah tennis shoes as well show
you how oh so I flipped it yeah you
flipped it yeah it shows you how in
touch I am with the youth so so what'd
you think when he first throws at I want
to resell Air Jordans and Jordans and
all this stuff look I'm not Sam can do
anything like he's he's not a guy that
lets you down like he's a person who
even if I don't know how to do it Jade
I'm gonna figure out how to do it so
when he said that at first because money
was
funny during the pandemic I was like um
at first I was like I don't know but
then I was like you know what it's Sam
yes that's all you did yes you just said
in Sam I trust and Sam I ask questions
okay no I was like come tell me when you
make some money well right but I love
that you didn't ask a bunch of questions
like What's it gonna cost what's your
margins she didn't do any of that but
yeah he he
so okay how did you get the idea this is
what I want people to hear how because
you were doing lots of different things
and it comes to you all right I I want
to do this I think I should do this okay
let me back up I didn't come to you with
the idea in 2020 I came in 2019 the end
of 2019 and and I'm saying this because
this could get awkward I don't know go
ahead because in 2019 I I came with the
idea I said hey I need 170 bucks I just
want to try this yeah and I I bought a
pair of Jordans for retail and I sold
them the next day for nine hundred
dollars I made like 750 bucks it just I
couldn't believe it I was shocked and so
now fast forward to 2020 you know for
the next year or 18 months I I kept
trying to do that over and over
basically like win the lottery okay and
that's not how it works and one day Jade
and I were talking and she was like dude
you're trying to be
the hair not the tortoise and I realized
that I just had struck lightning one
time and then I really needed to figure
out how this thing actually works and
that's when I really got into it but now
were you why did you initially like the
idea
um I've just it's one of those things
when I was a kid I love Jordans right
and I figured if I want to buy Jordans
what's a what's a better way to buy them
without spending like your own normal
budget money right then resell them yeah
so instead of house flipping you're a
Jordan flipper yeah that's what you I
mean on the side for fun right so okay
so now we've got the right timeline yeah
all right and so now she says you need
to be the tortoise what did that look
like so that looked like me going to uh
so
I had like 800 in this account that I
had made I piddled it all away trying to
figure out other things what that looked
like once I decided to be the tortoise I
basically had 170 bucks again I go to
Nike outlets and I'd buy
anything that there was a profit
marginal even if it was like ten dollars
yeah if if I I told myself if I can make
a 10 profit on this shoe I don't care if
it's five dollars that's a win right and
if I can make five dollars a hundred
times that's five so then you just
started doing this started stacking the
money and starting the money out yes I
figured it out the hard part the
discipline is you can't spend any of
that money you just have to keep
flipping it keep flipping it
um until you do have profit until you do
have profit that you can pull out of it
you know to the news and the more
profits you have then you could buy a
little bit more expensive shoe and then
have higher margin exactly so then I
stopped going to the outlets I started
going to the retail stores and you know
a lot of people what you'll see online
is a lot of people are trying to um
uh basically win these draws right I was
going to the mall doing the hard work I
went to the mall every day for 60 days
straight so give me a percentage what
kind of margins are you making now on
Jordans
it just depends on the shoe but well it
also depends on your customer because
that's a big part is using your network
yeah proximity principles kicked in big
time so I went from coming to you yeah I
got a lot of people coming to me and you
know we're musicians so I got a lot of
artists and athletes pro athletes and
stuff coming to me and so those shoes
have a bigger margin so I can make 100
or 200 percent on that you guys mind can
we share with the audience what kind of
money you're making on the side just in
this when he within them within a year
of him doing it he was putting about
five to five to seven hundred dollars on
the budget every month when I started
like when it picked up once it picked
that life so I said about it what are
you making now so on on a on a good
month
um I mean it varies I don't push as hard
as I once did because this was
sustaining us through covid but uh five
to the most I've made in a month is
seven thousand dollars
flipping Jordans folks
that's over 80 000 a year for those of
you that need a calculator uh that's
unbelievable money so uh here's why we
brought Sam in I wanted this audience to
see and hear the story here's what it
started out with something that he was
interested in he's a creative guy but he
wasn't designing and doing this he just
simply going I like shoes I like the
kicks I think there's margin here and he
began to do it on a disciplined level
after he figured out I'm not gonna
strike gold he stayed with it he's now
built a reputation and a clientele yeah
and he's figured out the fine print on
how to do it right we could go into deep
detail of how you find the shoes where
you find the shoes okay which one so
here's what I want you to hear the
takeaway from Sam warshaw is if you want
to have a side hustle that you're
willing to stick with and be disciplined
pick something that you really enjoy
you'll stick with it through the ups and
the Downs as you say that's true 100 you
stay excited about it
it's 80 000 plus dollars flipping
Jordans don't tell me yeah you can do
anything it's not alive and well my
goodness that's not a side hustle that's
a dream job for some of